que les députés monsieur le député Bruno
Studer grâce aux travaux que vous avez
menés avec le soutien du gouvernement la
France sera bientôt le 1er et pays du
monde à imposer le contrôle parental par
défaut sur tous les appareils
commercialisés sur son sol le décret
d'application a été validé par la
commission européenne et sera validée
prochainement ou en tout cas sera
examiné prochainement par le Conseil
d'État mais le combat doit continuer nos
enfants sont victimes en ligne
d'atteindre brutale à leur innocence et
à leur intimité a commencé par ce
scandale révoltant des Douzans un tiers
de nos enfants sont exposés aussi de
porno ce scandale nous comptons y mettre
fin nous comptons faire respecter la loi
avec Charlotte cobel avec l'arcom et la
CNIL nous présenterons demain les
conditions dans lesquelles les sites
pornos devront vérifier sérieusement
l'âge de leurs utilisateurs sous peine
de voir leur diffusion interdite sur le
territoire national
les violences faites aux enfants en
ligne ne s'arrêtent pas malheureusement
au porno chaque année dans notre pays un
million d'élèves sont touchés par le
cyber-harcèlement là aussi nous agissons
en lien avec le parlementaire le saluer
l'engagement d'Erwan Balanant sur le
sujet le ministre de l'éducation
nationale l'a rappelé récemment dès la
rentrée prochaine tous les élèves de 6e
bénéficieront d'un passeport internet
qui est sensibilisera aux risques et aux
attitudes à adopter lorsqu'ils sont
victimes ou témoins de cyber-harcèlement
mais vous l'avez dit face à l'insécurité
numérique la meilleure des digues c'est
la protection parentale la proposition
de loi que vous avez déposée elle mérite
de rappeler que les photos d'enfants qui
sont déposées sur les réseaux sociaux
tombent parfois entre de très mauvaises
mains nous devons éveiller les
consciences et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement lance
aujourd'hui une Vasse campagne de
communication autour du site je protège
mon enfant gouv.fr sur lequel les
parents pourront trouver tous les outils
pour protéger leurs enfants et les
accompagner dans l'espace numérique vous
le voyez que le député sous l'autorité
de la première ministre le gouvernement
agit et compte sur la mobilisation de
tous pour garantir à nos enfants le plus
haut niveau de sécurité dans l'espace
numérique